guys the jurassic world dominion trailer is
here we're here to cover this i'm so excited
i'm really really looking forward to this
movie couldn't have dropped at a better time
you covered peacemaker at midnight you stay up
all night going batman tickets are going on sale
is it gonna be like spider-man no way home and
then they drop this to help us pass the time
awesome hell yeah universal you did good this time
leave a like if you can let's get into it people
i wanted to show you something
that wasn't an illusion
how we've grown something that was real
mario something see and touch oh she's back
why is it gonna be crazy
live
we'll find a way
i love the winter setting we
can't keep her here forever
they find their one that's our job damn
straight humans and dinosaurs can't coexist
become an ecological disaster wow
you don't come out all this way just to
catch up now did you you coming or what
wow
we're racing toward the extinction of our species
okay that was that that's very
cool we're supporting the church
come back i always come back dancers
wow wow
the da vinci code jurassic
mission impossible dominion
it's another plane right not
exactly definitely holy christ
i am loving this so much
wow
why do they always have to go bigger
and malcolm
that was awesome that just made me
so happy now you got a good early
birthday present that time john
yeah maybe this one will be good
it looks like such a blast that looks like
a freaking blast that is a terrific trailer
oh my goodness i will say that is a terrific
trailer they're really doing something different
with jurassic park this time i love it man i'm
not a big fan of fallen kingdom i am a champion
for jurassic world i thought that movie was so
much fun a roller coaster and this feels like an
even bigger roller coaster they're truly following
through with the way it ended with fallen kingdom
and now we're in the future a little bit more and
dinosaurs are coexisting amongst humans can it
work and then come on they're really utilizing our
legacy characters you got luke han and leia right
there yeah we're home chewie it's so exciting
to see all three of them share the screen again
not since the first jurassic park they've been
teasing us and jeff goldblum and the second one
jeff goldblum fallen kingdom allen ellie in part
three now they're all back together i'm so glad
they gave us that money shot of them i mean that's
that's that's going to sell all the tickets right
there that's all anybody wanted to have confirmed
for them i mean even but the thing is even if
they weren't in the trailer i would this this
movie has my money it's coming out in june um
i thought it was next year june oh wow
that's so soon get your tickets so soon
it is right around the corner well i mean it's
been a long long time coming and obviously
pandemic delays but yeah there's something
you know i i refresh it does seem fret i i
i've you know have various reasons in the back of
my mind to be cynical because i'm not a big fan of
the jurassic world movies in general but each time
they put out a trailer they get me and this is my
favorite trailer of all three hands down i mean
i know they're multiple trailers but this yeah
i looked so kind of moody and exciting and yes
it has your legacy characters but what's getting
me going was just seeing the snow and the you know
environments yeah seeing them as actual animals in
situations that you associate terrestrial you
know current day and age animals with people
hurting them and these more sort of rural images
instead of having it be like attacked on coda of
jurassic park 2 where it's like oh yeah they're in
human society for a hot second it seems like yeah
we are going to live in that and we are going to
see what this next week it seems like we actually
might get a new status quo that isn't just oh we
really shouldn't have done this and now it's a
monster movie straightforward not that this won't
have those things because it absolutely will but
it definitely looks like something different from
the previous two movies but also that like you
said transitions perfectly out of the last
one i am surprised as anybody that i cannot
wait to see what this becomes it is such
an exciting trailer like this feels like
summer blockbuster it's doing all these types
of different summer blockbusters they literally
did mission impossible dominion right here yeah
with a little da vinci code sprinkled on top
they're like in rome or something so fascinating
to see how the plot of this unfolds is they're
traveling like what is the plot exactly is
there a plot here what is the plot or are
we just like going a location to location
they're gonna travel the globe i don't care
monsters back in the box let's see some t-rexes
in china i don't care where you go because we
gotta sell those tickets i know let's do it
from jurassic world architect and director
colin chavarro my man dominion takes place four
years after isla nebular has been destroyed
dinosaurs now live and hunt alongside humans all
over the world this fragile balance will reshape
the future and determine once or for all whether
human beings are to remain the apex partners on
a planet they now share with history's most
fearsome creatures dude nah they would whoop
my goodness like what is this so they're going to
have like peace treaty meetings with the dinosaurs
the dinosaurs gonna learn to talk they're gonna
negotiate alan like that's what i mean i want
to get a sense of like what what are the scenes
like because we're in the jungle we're in the snow
we're in europe we're in the sky you know we got
air tactics attacking our plane this just looks
like pure mayhem but also has that like wonder
gloss to it and sure i guess i'm excited for
chris pratt why not he's everyone's favorite chris
if i'm not missing you don't want owen and claire
to finish their rousing three movies i'll tell you
man um they are not that interesting in characters
but after bryce dallas howard's direction in the
book of boba fett i'm letting her direct one she's
not even in on camera in there but watching
her here i'm like you know i i love you so i'm
excited to see you because you're a good director
absolutely she is all right guys this trailer did
not disappoint i genuinely loved it that was
that was amazing it was a great trailer gotta
say hi that just made me so happy all right well
thanks for being here and uh we'll catch you soon
you